new york governor andrew cuomo is
stepping up national guard presence at
his state's airports the guard will be
enforcing a requirement for travelers to
new york
to get a coronavirus test before and
after they
arrive if they want to avoid a 14-day
quarantine
it comes as the u.s sets a record for
new covid19 infections
for a third straight day friday saw more
than 126 thousand new cases reported
9.7 million people have been infected
more than 236 thousand have died
tom hanson reports on the growing
concerns of this surge in cases
a massive wave of covid19 continues to
wash over america
with hot spots now stretching from the
heartland into the west
i'm not going to mince any words here
when it comes to the spread of the
coronavirus
we're on a very dangerous path denver
mayor michael hancock says
hospitalizations in his city
have jumped 40 percent in the last week
alone
his home by 10 curfew will go into
effect sunday with more severe options
looming
there's another stay-at-home order in
our future unless we
act with urgency and care for one
another
to change the behavior that is leading
to these increasing
cases in oregon governor kate brown has
ordered a two-week pause on social
activities
in counties with high caseloads please
please please limit your social
interactions
to your own household for those of you
who have scheduled events with other
people for the coming weekend
please cancel them we need your help
stronger measures are already taking
effect across europe
luxury department stores in milan closed
friday in a partial lockdown
while drivers in athens rushed home in
advance of greece's
three-week lockdown are you getting
towards feeling that you need to
advocate for the kinds of national
lockdowns that we're seeing across the
uk and europe now or do you think the
u.s
isn't in that place no we're not we're
not in that place now in a virtual
interview friday with the oxford union
debate society in england
dr anthony fauci acknowledged there's
little appetite for similar stay-at-home
orders in the u.s
voucher reiterated the need to wear
masks in socially distance
and said a vaccine could be available as
early as next month
i don't like overconfidence but i can
tell you that i'm cautiously optimistic
that a vaccine is going to take us out
of this very difficult position
for cbs this morning saturday tom hanson
new york